da hängt die genannten aufmacht die
konfettikanone ankünfte insekt endlich
gute nachrichten endlich endlich endlich
ist die nachricht da es wird gut werden
es hieß ja immer es kommt im ersten
quartal 2021 auch das ist ja gut aber
noch schöner dass sie die nachricht
jetzt haben dass wir zu weihnachten
quasi den impfstoff kriegen dass dann
die ersten alten die ersten flieger die
ersten ärzte auf den intensivstationen
geimpft werden können yahoo deutschland
kann die dann nur sagen dass es wirklich
eine großartige nachricht
und ja freut mich für alle die mit dem
stoff kriegen werden schnelle kriegen
wir das dann mal ins detail gehen die
alle die den impfstoff schnell kriegen
werden wie lange wird dieser prozess
sollte es jetzt auch alles gut gehen mit
dezember wie lange wird dieser prozess
dauern bis 60 müssen geimpft seien in
deutschland bis wir dieses ziel ungefähr
erreicht hat also stand heute weiß nicht
wie viele impfstoffe da noch kommen und
in welchen mengen stand heute wird das
dauern bis ins jahr 2022 hinein also
eineinhalb jahre wird das auf jeden fall
dauern aber die gute nachricht ist dass
erstmal die geschützt werden dies ganz
besonders brauchen alte chronisch kranke
risikopatienten und vor allem flieger in
den altenheimen auf die intensivstation
die ärzte und die leute die in den
täglichen einsatz müssen feuerwehrleute
sanitäter polizisten die werden geimpft
werden und das ist eine wirklich
wirklich gute nachricht die
nebenwirkungen sind von bayern text
jetzt bekannt geworden und die
nebenwirkungen sind der der so genannten
dritten grades also oder der dritten
stufe
das ist kopfschmerz ermüdung und ab und
zu abgeschlagen der abgeschlagenheit
glaube damit kann man leben oder also
damit kann man auf jeden fall leben und
warum gegen alles jetzt so schnell viele
menschen haben vielleicht das gefühl
wurde dass ausreichend getestet ja es
wurde getestet wie jeder andere im shop
auch das ist der unterschied auch
nochmal zu der zu der zulassung in den
usa das auch ausführlich getestet worden
also liegen die dieselben daten
vorarbeiter geht man halt jetzt
schneller durch das papier durch bei uns
in europa hat man es anders gemacht man
hat ein sonderweg genommen ist ist auch
eine situation wie sie auch in der
medizingeschichte so noch nicht da war
das eine krankheit da es weltweit und
man dann einen impfstoff nach entwickelt
und dann wirklich schnell was die ganze
welt kämpfen will
und da hat man von dermaßen gemacht man
hat quasi eine laufende prüfung gemacht
also im verfahren während die tests
liefen während stufe 3 es gibt da eins
zwei drei stufen in diesen tests während
die tests liefen hat man die fertigen
daten schon eingereicht als es wurde per
ausgewertet von den genehmigungsbehörden
ihren permanent die ergebnisse wird
bekommen und haben dann diese nackten
berg der der wird die räume füllen
füllen kann durchgearbeitet zu dem
zeitpunkt wo stufe 3 beendet war der
tests da waren die fast schon durch die
haben jetzt also noch so nach lauf von
drei vier wochen denen die brauchen also
33 wochen etwa oder vier bis sie dann
die genehmigungen geben können was sie
alles durch haben normalerweise ist es
dann wäre es so gewesen
man hat ein impfstoff entwickelt man hat
die unterlagen sortiert die unterlagen
werden dann immer mal kopiert und dann
werden die unterlagen weggefahren und
dann kommen die irgendwo an und da
sitzen die behörde da und gräbt sich der
langsam durch und irgendwann fast man
mal zusammen also dieses verfahren ist
dass erstmals so abgekürzt worden
deswegen ging es so schnell es ging so
schnell
bei der bund und die europäische union
ungeheuren mittel in die hand genommen
haben um das möglichst immer das muss
man einfach auch mal sagen an so einem
schönen tag
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren